with her deadly aim
should pierce into the heart of a
hummingbird
i entire things all of them
i see you there
come
none of this is
reflections from a broken mirror
behold your god
this one killed six innocent children
to satisfy her age they squabble
far with chelsea she
fight and murder their cool
vindictive and selfish and
let the heel of achilles these
weaknesses
will be
now i missed you prometheus my
favorite castle you chained me to this
rock
and fed my liver to an eagle out of love
you need my help typhon
is free you once fought beside his
allies
the titans convince him to stand down
it's not that simple he is even blocking
my ability to glimpse the future
i cannot see past him
go on blast me
my god he took my lightning he took
everything
even the other gods are missing
look to the mortals that's
done those evil imbecillic
tasteless parasites were all turned to
stone
one of those evil parasites is about to
save your royal
ass my ass is safely lodged in the
aegean stables
and mortals will never be anything but a
mistake
care to make a wager if i'm right
my sin of stealing fire and ensuring
their survival
becomes a blessing you
find your punishment unjust it's a
little
[Music]
extreme do we have a deal
if you win i'll end your punishment and
set you free
but if i win you help me stop typhon
whatever it takes very
well let the tale of phoenix
be my redemption oh no
not one of your stories how long is this
going to
my tale begins at sea a ship of soldiers
returning from a far away battle their
victory
ambushed by an unexpected storm
the sea tossed and turned waves churned
to a frog
the line between sky and sea all but
vanished the mountainous peaks of the
waves
descended into valleys nearly as deep as
turtles
you're really painting a picture here
it's an art point is the ship
didn't stand a chance
at dawn the sun rose on the few
remaining survivors
the lowest ranked among them a shield
bearer
who dreamt of battle but had seen nerius
don't tell me there i see
her clear as day
the lowest ranked among them a shield
bearer
who dreamt of battle but had seen aries
skirmish
a teller of tales not a doer of deeds
phoenix what a name
phoenix sounds like the sound a dumb
bird makes
when it lights itself on fire which
would be
ridiculous although
i should write that down
washed up on an unknown shore phoenix
awoke
yay
look a ghost captain can anyone hear me
looks like the only way off this beach
is up that cliff
huh
phoenix saw her captain and fellow
soldiers in the distance
through a trick of the light she could
almost see them waving and calling to
her
phoenix again you may not be your
brother liguiron
but i will make something of you yet
hold my shield
try not to drop it this time i didn't
see you there
don't let them get to you they're just
jealous it's not often someone
has a brother like yours
local ghost local ghost can you hear me
you've gone cold what the magic is this
lageron where are you brother
unarmed and lost phoenix was vulnerable
i have to be calm i have to follow my
training
my brother sword no
[Music]
brother
you've always been my hero my north star
i will bring you back i swear it
[Music]
[Music]
phoenix had never been allowed to hold
the hallowed sword
a gift from achilles for bravery
he balanced perfectly in his palm
as he forged for it achilles
is something wrong with your voice i
never got a sword
just say phoenix
by the gods stay back
she readied her soul for her first real
[Music]
fight
phoenix felt her training come into
focus
i should be able to survey the land from
up there
this is the largest statue of hermes
i've ever seen
i wonder who built it besieged by
challenge
totally alone this young hero was
determined to save her fellow soldiers
and brother boring can we skip this path
no this is important for the sense of
[Music]
atmosphere
hermes my old friend it's an honor to
finally meet you in person
just don't tell anyone i'm speaking to
you i got in enough trouble for
memorizing stories instead of tilling
the soil back at home
and then the other soldiers well
they really don't appreciate the good
story
[Music]
uh
[Music]
huh
phoenix's destiny was becoming clear
so far all you have shown me is a mortal
soldier who has fought
one real battle and typhon grows
stronger by the hour
don't toy with me prometheus
i swear to you that soldier shall be our
salvation
for if she fails and typhon defeats us
zeus king of gods the world will fall to
chaos a temple of apollo
if it has an oracle or a seer they could
help me undo this curse
griffin but they aren't real let me go
hey i'll save you
i'm coming
i need to find a way to reach that rift
how to get down the pond
phoenix felt like iron's blade with
every step
its weight a reminder of the heavy
responsibility you gave him your blade
oh achilles i meant to ask
why exactly would you expect to receive
a sword from achilles
oh as an offering just a routine
offering from someone
who gazed into your eyes and told you
you were special
that's all i left a rose
on his breastplate got something in my
eye
keep going
who's done this to you prometheus stop
with the mortal bitty party and get to
the action part
fine now that's more likely
[Music]
the aromantic shed by typhon's minions
metal of the gods threw itself to
phoenix
as if wanting to be forged into
something greater
i'll have to swim to the other shore
it smells like honey and the first day
of spring
and my first kiss all rolled into one
phoenix got into the ambrosia too
prometheus
hello can you hear me in there
i'm coming
i found your axe phoenix approached the
axe
feeling it called to her
looks like the acts of atalanta must be
a copy
although but before phoenix could claim
it
the axe was pulled into the pit by a
terrible force
who knocks upon my door
no one you think that aldrich will
work on me coming to my partner
said the cyclops to the sale
you worried zeus about losing this bet
please she can't use it anyway
yes well
that's the end of phoenix perfectly
possible
storytelling i won't lie there were
moments that dragged but you really got
me with that ending
now let's settle up time for you to help
me against typhon
it's not over yet not by a long shot
ah
what what is this place
indeed what was this strange
place it's tartarus just exactly where
had phoenix landed
tatoros the nasty abyss where i
imprisoned typhon
he must have opened rifts into the
vaults of the underworld when he escaped
you know it i know say it phoenix was in
uh
i hate you but aren't you intrigued
no keep going
you are brave little one
or very foolish let's see if you can
meet my talent or if you will fall
like all the others who are you
hello
huh
[Music]
what
what's this wings
phoenix ran her hands over them noticing
that
several pieces were missing as if
someone
had ripped them apart they seem to be
man-made
i wonder how they work if they even work
you